at first though we begin with breaking
news and we are getting reports that two
rockets have hit a border area in
southern turkey local media are
reporting that one of the Rockets hit a
school in the district of
carcamisoglo is in Istanbul synonym what
are you learning
uh
oh how much that someday the stumble
bombing attack with the events as the
Turkish authorities have identified the
Assyrian turdish Fighter Group ypg as
the perpetrator uh the Y and a launched
a very large scale air campaign against
the ypg and PK post simultaneously in
Northern Iraq and Northern Syria we
heard from the ypg officials that took a
Turkish residential areas would also be
targeted so this is what's been
happening this is the first time that
turkey a southern residential areas have
been targeted by the ypg since the peace
spring operation uh that uh that started
late 2019 and it was very normal as the
the security settlements are very close
to the Turkish border from time to time
a Turkish Army throws missiles and from
the other other side Kurdish forces also
uh fire some Rockets to the Turkish land
but usually they they they were hitting
the
um rural area the Farms basically this
was the first summer residential area
has been hit for nearly uh two and two
and a half years or something and a
primary school has been hit and since
the ypg also claimed that the Turkish
Air Force has targeted their own
civilian settlements during uh during
the uh air operation conducted by the
Turkish Army many expect that these
kinds of harassment fires
May probably continue
I'm gonna send them because they're
reporting from Istanbul on events in
southern turkey air thank you very much